on sort on a tous ce pote un peu cool
sur facebook qui connaît toutes les
bonnes adresses alors d'avoir le style
de vie d'un millionnaire alors qu'il est
soit disant au smic depuis notre âme de
métro on voit ces photos parachute
ascensionnel ou tu de san francisco aux
frais d'un local sympathique bon on n'a
pas forcément envie d'être ce bot
on aimerait bien pouvoir en profiter
aussi parfois nous aussi imaginer
quelqu'un qui vous souffle ses bons
plans qui vous conseille juste en
discutant avec lui qui apprend à vous
connaître connaître vous votre contexte
puis gratuitement vous par de bonnes
adresses pour vous aider à passer des
bons moments mais c'est ce dont j'ai
rêvé et j'ai décidé de le créer enfin
pas vraiment en fait au départ j'ai créé
une plateforme des changes pour les
étudiants que j'étais alors vous pouvez
tout y partager des as par des stages
des soirées trottinette abandonné la
plateforme a eu un succès mitigé
en langage start up ça veut dire un
échec bon pourtant on avait mis doigt
sur quelque chose on répondait à un vrai
besoin
nos utilisateurs chercher quand même
quelque chose un outil pour répondre à
leurs demandes
mais la plateforme que nous jeunes
entrepreneurs en herbe avec des étoiles
plein les yeux on avait imaginé la
solution toute faite qu'on a laissé deux
plaques et ont bien que mal entre leurs
mains étaient pas adapté alors on a tout
jeté deux ans de code de design de sueur
et on a proposé une vingtaine
d'étudiants de venir nous voir dans nos
bureaux et nous raconter un peu ce
qu'ils pensaient de nouvelles idées
d'appli révolutionnaire et alors là
autre surprise il en avait rien à faire
d'avoir une énième appli d'avoir
apprendre à l'utiliser de se créer un
compte de la télécharger ce qu'il
voulait c'était quelqu'un qui les aident
à résoudre un problème qu'ils ont bien
précis en tête trouver un bar pour
emmener leurs dettes hinder une des
cadeaux pour les 50 ans de leur maman
est en stage à new york une salle de gym
près de chez eux
donc on arrêter d'essayer leur faire
tester l'application
et on s'est mis autour d'une table on
s'est attelé à répondre à ces problèmes
très concrètement nous faut imaginer une
bande de sept jeunes diplômés qui
répondent de vie voire puis par email
par sms et enfin par messenger ce qu'on
fait encore aujourd'hui à ces demandes
et donc on est là autour d'une table
avec des post its on note toutes nos
actions nos idées nos blocages et tous
les quarts d'heure loïc mon associé
ingénieurs les collègues et collectent
ces post it et dès qu'on voit qu'on fait
quelque chose plus trois fois à la main
il le code et c'est comme ça que le
premier algorithmes de classification de
message d' analyse de requêtes de
recherche contenu même de génération de
textes sont nés et donc ça marche
au bout de trois semaines ses vents
étudiants de départ un peu sceptiques
sont devenus 800 ils se passent le mot
et nous font part de leurs demandes
diverses et variées et on y répond on
essaie d'être un peu malin donc on
industrialise le process d'abord à
l'aide d'un outil existant et puis par
petit itération ont construit notre
propre back office basé sur
l'intelligence artificielle qui peut
recevoir des demandes et y répondre et
nous sommes vraiment m'en rendre compte
je me retrouve à développer à construire
une entreprise basée sur l'intelligence
artificielle
je dirais pas que ça me tomber dessus
mais disons que l'intelligence
artificielle pour nous ça n'a jamais été
une fin en soi ç'a toujours été un moyen
est ce que je peux vous raconter
c'est l'histoire de la naissance de
jeanne mon entreprise qui est ce qu'on
appelle un jour de chat bottes mi humain
mi intelligence artificielle une
intelligence artificielle
conversationnel aujourd'hui on est une
équipe de 15 à développer ce service qui
est gratuit
on échange jamais en tout cas échanges
en moyenne un message toutes les dix
secondes et on se rémunère et grâce à
aux bons plans aux offres négociées
qu'on va les chercher pour répondre aux
besoins des utilisateurs
en fait on est un peu comme un concert
du kif gratuit pour tout le monde qui
peut vous réserver un resto sur la
fourchette
vous êtes organisé votre prochain
week-end lancer une playlist trouver un
bar et cet été pensez un peu posé on a
fait le bilan
de ce qu'a fait la valeur de jam est ce
qui nous a motivés à elle crée alors au
départ oui c'était pour aider les
étudiants dans leur galère mais
aujourd'hui on a l'opportunité d'avancer
des d'encore plus de gens m'ont
conseillé poser la question pour quelle
douleur dans quel contexte dans quel but
une autre vision chez jam c'est d'aider
chacun à prendre les meilleures
décisions
une bonne décision si l'alliance un peu
magique de deux choses c'est avoir la
bonne information et avoir la capacité
de passer à l'action
voilà une bonne décision oui mais
pourquoi
en tout cas il faut bien commencer par
un angle on n'a pas envie de faire
quelque chose complètement à nos temps
quel temps fait-il dehors combien y
at-il de pingouins en antarctique
oui on a eu cette question et on ya
répondu ni complètement quelque chose de
déterminant pour votre vie votre premier
appartement un emploi au milieu de tout
ça une chose qui me semble intéressant
qui nous plaît qui nous motive c'est le
temps libre les bons moments et des
légendes qui s'adresse à jam a trouvé
des choses sympas affaires qui leur
correspondent pour leur bon moment ça
pose les vraies questions
il faut apprendre à vous connaître à
connaître vos goûts même si définir les
valeurs et le mode de fonctionnement de
notre intelligence artificielle parce
que lorsque vous échangez avec
intelligence artificielle
lorsque vous interagissez avec elle
c'est très différent que d'interagir
avec une interface sur un site ou une
application vous entrez dans une vraie
relation qui est basée sur les changes
sur la confiance sur la régularité
alors oui lundi gentil ficelles au début
elle vous propose des petites choses à
vous recommander des bars des restos des
week-ends des playlists et film mais
régulièrement et mis bout-à-bout ça peut
avoir un vrai impact sur votre vie en
tout cas je l'espère sinon je ne serais
pas là est la question qui se pose c'est
comment on va qualifier cet impact de
positif des recommandations pertinentes
personnalisés certes c'est une évidence
mais les valeurs de l'intelligence
artificielle et son mode de
fonctionnement sont aussi très
importantes
prenons un exemple qui peut paraître
anodin vous dites avec intelligence
artificielle que vous avez faim elle
vous propose un burger près de chez vous
qui al'air appétissant peut-être même
avec une réduction
sauf sensibilité alimentaire contraire
vous serez sûrement satisfait mais si à
chaque fois que vous avez faim elle vous
propose un burger là ça paraît anodin
mais en extrapolant on peut commencer à
comprendre les enjeux réels que ça pose
pour votre santé et d'autres aspects de
votre vie parce que prendre une question
il répond comme si c'était un besoin
isolés que quelqu'un venait de
s'adresser à jams adressé comme sur un
site une interface est juste cherché à
répondre à ces critères le mettre dans
ses habitudes
oui c'est un choix que certains
algorithmes autour de nous faut c'est un
choix de design c'est un joueur de la
part des entrepreneurs des ingénieurs
derrière une intelligence artificielle
mais l'intelligence artificielle elle
peut au contraire par le choix de
surprendre de sortir des habitudes des
sentiers battus et c'est ça selon nous
le grand défi de l'intelligence
artificielle est notre responsabilité à
tous j'ai bien on a défini ce qui fait
ce sont nos valeurs
les a définis elle gitta façon dont on
crée le produit et la technologie
derrière ces des valeurs de
bienveillance c'est encourager mêmes
récompenses et l'ouverture d'esprit
l'émerveillement la sérendipité la
surprise très concrètement dans le
produit une recommandation ça va se
traduire par démystifier les plats ou
quinoa rancoule une expo classique dans
la technologie rajouter notion d'
aléatoire dans les algorithmes faire des
propositions qui correspond pas
exactement toujours aux critères exacts
de l'utilisateur rappelons une chose
toute simple
l'intelligence artificielle elle est au
service de l'homme alors pas uniquement
par philosophie mais aussi par
contrainte économique pour assurer sa
viabilité
si l'intelligence artificielle elle vous
propose toujours la même chose qu'elle
dépasse pas d'une certaine façon l'état
de l'art de l'action humaine on les
qualifiera pas d'intelligence pour avoir
l'air intelligente elle doit un peu
rompre les habitudes elle doit s'adapter
à vos exigences
à vos contraintes étant que vous
attendez et que vous exigez même d'être
surpris de bouger de votre canapé
les ingénieurs les designers les
entrepreneurs derrière les algorithmes
devront s'adapter
l'intelligence
officiel c'est pas juste construit par
une bande de geeks fou en sweat à
capuche dans des caves
c'est dès aujourd'hui par nos millions
de clics de petits choix de petites
décisions de petites préférences
l'intelligence artificielle c'est pas
une lubie futuriste on imagine en train
de faire décoller et atterrir des fusées
mais plus concrètement plus modestement
aujourd'hui elle nous recommande des
films à voir nous suggère des amis a
ajouté
elle nous incite à lire des articles
donc si on prend cet exemple des
articles s'informer par soi même aller
chercher l'information diversifier ses
sources et pas toujours par des articles
recommandé c'est un message un petit
message à envoyer aux algorithmes et à
ceux qui les conçoivent donc la
prochaine fois quand précipité votre
pouce ou votre souris sur un article
conseiller recommandé et qui titre et si
trump était un personnage disney fesci
saisi à deux secondes
ce sera un petit acte de résistance
voire d'intelligence merci